every writer has to find their own
process
so outlines don't work for everybody
beat sheets
don't work for everybody treatments
don't work for everybody you have to
figure out what works well for you
i start with somewhat of an outline um i
need to know
where i am and then where i'm going or
where i just came from
so usually for me personally when i'm
starting to write it's not coming from a
from a starting place it's coming from a
scene i already had
so i write that scene out the most vivid
thing about what i think about this idea
i write that scene out without any it
doesn't have to fit anywhere i don't
know where this is but i just see
these characters doing this at some
point so i start there kind of kind of
get my groove going and start
to like yeah i really feel this moment
i've seen this moment i'm very a very
visual writer and a very
when ideas come to me they come to me
almost as like a movie um so i'm able to
write that down
and then now i go to an outline because
i don't i don't even know where this is
so i know i'm here but i don't know
where this is in the story or anything
like that
um so i just start with okay where's it
ending where are we going
and then go from there so i kind of in a
very non-linear way
bounce about the outline and then in the
end which to outline could take two
months i mean in the end i see it and
i'm like
okay now this is some type of map with
the understanding that we can deviate
from it
what i do is i outline a script
very meticulously and my outlines are
about 25 pages to 30 pages long
and then when i go to write the actual
first draft
i will not re-read one word of what i've
written
until i've written the whole script so
for my first pass on a screenplay
i start from the beginning and then i
just go and i go all the way through
until i'm done without having read one
word of it
and it takes about three weeks so in
three weeks i've written a whole draft
and it's a lot of fun
because there is no judgment whatsoever
i'm just writing straight through
and then i go through and very
meticulously work through the scenes
and that takes two to three weeks and
then in six weeks i have a draft
but it's really two drafts because i've
done one straight through
and then one this sort of meticulous
work through and i will say that the
second
phase of it the meticulous work through
phase is
uh the least enjoyable part of the whole
process
because it's the most critical where i
just for a couple weeks
it's just i have to work through these
scenes and and
but i just do it and then after that i
have a draft to work off of
and then there's many drafts after that
but it's it's i have this nice
foundation
i would first off see what's the story
what's what's the
genre and why do you want to tell it
in three words give me three words about
the story
it could be just three three words
revenge
um another word so we'll start with
those words then give me a character
who do you want in the character
then i'll go ask okay where's this take
place
um get the character what's the
character's job what does that person do
and what does that character want to do
and then
develop the world develop the character
and why do you want to tell that story
and we'll start from there and then go
out
go back and then just even if it's one
page
or two page or three pages um
write something about what this
character does in that world with their
job and
when what what they want to do and then
once you have
that then we could flesh it out a little
bit more and then
then maybe like you said start an
outline
um what what do they need what's the
obstacles
um and and then we add more characters
in
but i i would probably start with um who
the
who the main character is and um in the
world they're in
i usually i email them to myself so i
have all these random emails that
that half the time don't make sense like
you know you know
second act all on on a plane giant fight
you know
guy loses his wife you know hit man
finds out his ex-wife is married to
somebody else
yeah things like that so i have all
these weird random things but then
once i really dig in i have a process to
figure out if something can be
a script and usually it's i figure out
the entire first act
beat by beat by beat like the first 20
pages this happens that happens this
happens like the first six or seven
scenes
then i know what happens in the second
hack turn kind of what shifts the movie
or the story and then how it ends and if
i can figure all that out
then i know i pretty much can write a
pretty good script
so that's usually what i do first i
don't want to know the whole story beat
by beat by beat because i figured some
things out
along the way that i would have never
thought of now there's other times i've
kind of thought the whole thing out
almost
you know in in more you know bigger
beats and bigger sections but
that's usually what it is i know the
first act how it ends
what happens in the middle and then what
happens at the end and that's it
usually the idea is that that i can't
stop
thinking about are the ones i know are
good they keep
popping back in my head because there's
some ideas you you know just come up
with
nah throw it away you know it's pretty
good but it's not great
but the ones that keep reoccurring you
know
are the ones that you know i i feel like
okay i gotta work on this there's
something here because it's stuck in my
head and also too you know ideas are
great testing ground with people too
i mean this is for more like commercial
type films but if you can
pitch an idea in two three sentences you
know um
to somebody just your friends or whoever
and they kind of do this weird thing
i've noticed
this is when you have a good idea not
when people go that's great when they
think about it for about
three seconds and they go oh that's good
that's when you know it's actually
connecting with people so you know if
you have an idea and you say that to 10
people and they kind of all go
or they ask you about it again later you
know it's a good idea
there are several different ways you can
start a screenplay
and a lot of that goes back to whatever
your idea is it's probably thing that's
going to come to you first
but you should definitely then start
trying to figure out what all the rest
of those elements are
so figuring out what the world is
knowing what the tone is a lot of people
may not think about tone but tone
matters
uh tone is that um that that um
that that feeling that makes this
different from
slapstick comedy regular comedy romantic
comedy
into kind of a comedic drama
that is now more regular drama family
drama that ends up now this gritty
thriller thing so
it's kind of like the the nuance between
the genres right like what that tone
is um and then knowing who your
characters are
knowing who's going to go on this
journey figuring out why we should care
about them
um figuring out how we're going to
relate to them and relating to them
doesn't have to mean liking them we just
have to relate
um then knowing what goal they're after
because anything that's on tv
anything that's on uh anything that's a
feature is about a character reaching a
goal that's why we're here
we don't want to just see people go
through their day-to-day lives right we
want to see
like their act or something or
something's after them you know whatever
it is
but they have a goal um figuring out
what the stakes are the stakes are going
to be the why
why am i here why do i care what's
what's going on what are they going to
win what are they going to lose
because if not then why do i care if
they reach the goal if they don't if
there's nothing at stake for them
then i am going to be that much less
invested
um and people usually know what the end
is people usually kind of know what the
setup is
and they kind of know what the
resolution is right it's the second act
where everyone kind of falls apart and
it's because we
really don't start asking our ques
asking ourselves
how how are they going to get from a
to b so i personally feel like everyone
should write an outline
there are going to be writers who are
reading this like ha i've never read an
outline and i've done great that's great
you might have that special skill you
know you also might be a person
who doesn't mind rewriting 15 times
because no matter what you're going to
rewrite right
i think by writing the outline you cut
down the number of rewrites because your
first draft
isn't as terrible because you've
actually plotted out
what it is you're going to do so you
didn't just start at the blank page and
start writing and just like you know oh
well maybe they'll go this way and maybe
they go that way
because as soon as you change one thing
what does it do changes everything else
there's a domino effect
if you're doing that in outline form for
some people that's putting it on cards
some people that's putting it on a white
board
you know now you just erase that one
little part and write it write it back
or you move your
your cards around because you realize
this scene could probably be best there
and it heightens the stakes if we make
this thing happen here
i do mine in a word document and i put
um the actual
uh scene heading on top and then
whatever's happening in that scene
so i can copy and paste that whole
little thing all over the place if i
want to
so it's easier to kind of see your story
on paper
and move it around as much as you'd like
before it gets into script format
then it becomes a little harder to do
that so if you have an outline and you
really
understand how does this person get from
a to c what happens during b
what do they physically do so i'm always
asking
how and so people will then answer that
with with a general answer and i'll go
no no
i want to know what the character's
physically doing like what am i watching
them do
you say well they're saving the world
how are they saving the world by going
to starbucks
are they saving the world by having to
go confront a bad guy
yes they have to confront the bad guy
how how did they find him
where was he was he just down the street
was he you know in another country
he's in another country how do they get
there you know do they
take a bus do they take a train do they
have to fly do they swim
you know like all of these little
details about how
we actually get from a to c are the
things that people don't think about
until they're
on the page and then they're then
they're stuck and they stop and they're
like i can't get past this part
and it's like yeah because you didn't
think about that part until you got here
but if you took some time to figure it
out before you get to the writing part
now the writing is fun because you got
your notes and you're like oh okay this
is what's supposed to be happening right
now
oh okay i get it and now it can happen a
little more clean
than it would have if you just went
straight to the page and so now
maybe instead of doing five rewrites you
only have to do two
if i've already printed out my
directions or if i have
my google maps on my phone then i know
where i'm going
i say i can't this is not a good example
i was going to say
i could say i want to drive to louisiana
but if i don't look it up i can't get
there
i happen to know where louisiana is from
here so i could probably get there but
there are other people who are like
who would have no idea that they can get
on i-10
and get all the way to louisiana some
people might not know that
but um so they would need to have those
directions if you don't have those
directions now you're
veering you know left and now you've
taken a wrong turn and now you've done x
y and z
and you've wasted however many hours
trying to get there when you could've
had a straight shot if you just had
the directions so to me that's what an
outline is
it's your google maps so that you know
where you're going so i think beginning
writers should definitely start in that
place well start by learning structure
right start by understanding what
elements it takes to have
a story and then outline
in my writing process i actually i have
a weird process i've
read this book uh called the mind of the
maker by dorothy l
sayers and it's a fascinating book i
recommend to anybody in the creative
field she wrote in 19 1941 it came out
and she was a mystery writer but she
wrote this one it was about she's trying
to write a book of theology but
in trying to explain the mind of of a
god
she uses artists and writers as an
example
and it's a one of the things i loved
about it is she said that as a creator
you create the world you create the
physics of it and the laws of it and you
create the people that inhabit it
but then you give them free will and
to me that is the most organic form of
writing and so
my writing process is i try to i try to
just see the world and try to understand
it and know who my characters are and
the premise
and then i literally just i ferment on
that for a while until i feel like i
have an understanding i'll write notes
and stuff like that
and then i literally just sit down and
write
and just when it comes to a plot point
like what would they do here what would
they do
here and letting the character i've
conjured my mind have that free will to
make those choices instead of me guiding
them
the only time i feel like i hit a
writer's block now is when
i'm trying to force them to do something
they wouldn't do
and so that is kind of my writing
process and then once i have a first
draft
out that's when i then go back and start
asking myself those questions like okay
here's some of the themes i wanted to
address
that maybe aren't as clear or in it how
do i put that into it how do i
is there a way place where this works is
there a place where this works
i don't set up a structure i don't set
up markers i don't have any plot points
i write down
it's like here's the world here's the
characters let's see where we go
so for better for worse the writing
style that works for me we'll see what
audiences feel but i enjoy it i
comes out much more organically i don't
get writer's block
um it just takes a lot longer to write
that first page because you're trying to
figure out
all the aspects of the world that
they're in all the people
that are there but once you have that
all
just kind of let them loose in your
brain and see what happens
the first process is getting the log
line down where you have that
the log line and you have that hint of
irony it's it's um
you know um just you know
boiling it down to a sentence that you
can pitch to somebody like what's it
about
and you know people get it right away
um from there once i think you have that
locked in
then it's a matter of really breaking it
out into um
you know the main components of the
story and the structure for me that
is where i've really become a lot more
um
fastidious with my process of you know
knowing
like again what's the hard turn what's
the you know what's that inciting
incident how does it affect the
character
what's sending them off to that to that
first act turn turning point
then from there to the midpoint and then
intact three and how they're changing
along the way
um i think it was you know i was uh i'm
sure like
every writer you know obviously read the
blake snyder
you know save the cat and i think
honestly that's
that's probably the most uh
comprehensive book on
screenwriting i i would i recommend that
anyone who's
looking to break in i always tell them
to get
you know save the cat save the cat goes
to the movies
because i think blake snyder was really
on to something um
so i really do follow i believe it's the
16 major beats that
he laid out in there and and you know
their purpose
and for me that really i think
you know i was going in that direction
before
i read the blake snyder novel but
certainly after and
and and he was also such an inspiring
writer um
uh blake snyder was but getting a good
idea
of you know how to you know really lay
out the story and how to structure it
that to me is is again is the most
important part of the process
you know i think once you have your log
line and your structure you know
you know the writing it's probably about
60 70 percent of the process i think the
actual writing is about 30 percent
you know because if you everything lined
up you know where your character's going
you know their journey
um it's going to make things a lot
easier for you um and of course things
will always change and you have to be
open and flexible i know some people who
write
30 page outlines 40 page outlines i
usually try to keep it between 6 and 8
pages
um just because i feel like if you're
with an outline like that you sort of
lose some of the momentum the creativity
where if you have a good idea and you're
you really have a good structure in
place knowing you know what
what scene comes after what scene comes
after what scene and it's this
you know um snowball that keeps rolling
up
um you know if you keep it tight in
those first
and that that outline and then from
there you can use that and then just
transfer it to
uh the final final draft or the actual
script
you know i think then you have good
momentum
to keep to keep the flow the creative
flow going for sure and giving leaving
yourself room for some flexibility
because things will always come up
and um certainly hasn't anything that
i've ever written
i first start with a
notebook once i've decided okay this is
a project that i want to
write i buy a notebook for it i usually
try to sort of
theme the notebook so if it's like a old
like pirate adventure
i'll try to make it look i'll find a
notebook that looks like that um
and then i would just use that notebook
to just freehand
write anything i'm interested in in
regards to this
screenplay whether it's just like a very
vague idea of
i think this thing should happen or i'm
writing
a dialogue for a scene that might exist
in the screenplay i'm sort of
filling that notebook up and i don't
really have a timeline at that point
so i'm talking about spec scripts for me
i'm just
writing it right in it writing it until
hopefully a story will
coalesce and once i feel like
that story's coalesced i'll try to write
that
story as succinctly impossible
essentially i'm trying to write the log
line for it
and if that log line is engaging to me
and i think will move me if i think that
story
that is told even in that little you
know one sentence
is moving enough to me i'll try to take
that sentence and i'll
turn it into a paragraph and if that
paragraph
is moving then i'll move on if it's not
i will continue to maybe reshape
that paragraph and then that paragraph
will become
a page that page will become multiple
pages into sort of a treatment
and then at the treatment that's when i
think i'm doing most of my story work
i'm
writing that over and over and i will do
that for
a couple of months maybe depending on
how often i can
work on it and once that treatment
is really resonating with me and is a
story
that again will move me then i can take
it and
start writing the draft and so it almost
feels like that draft is more like a
translation
project than writing something new
i'm taking something that exists in full
prose writing and then
put it into a screenplay format and so
all of the
little things that
exist in a screenplay that's when i'm
putting those things in because my story
i feel
i already feel incredibly comfortable
about so i don't have to discover any of
the story things i just discover all
those little things all those little
nooks and crannies
that happen when a story is now going to
be put on the screen and i'm translating
it there
and then i'll get that first draft and
then from that i'm moving into
rewrites and polishes and all those sort
of conversations
but i think it's helped me because i
feel like my story
usually doesn't go through too many
significant changes
once i'm on that draft once i'm in the
screenplay software and writing it
because all those changes i've hit all
those dead ends all those
things that i thought were great that
are not all those things that i was
excited about that didn't end up
doing anything for me i've already
figured that out
in that treatment process so i don't
outline so much as try to just
tell a story and tell it fuller and
fuller
until that's a full rich story and then
translate it to a screenplay if that
makes sense
if we're really going to like the start
start i'm watching a movie
that i love like i like my my
aforementioned matrix
revisit revisiting where i was like
ideas were just fireworks in my brain
after that i have to
you know all these ideas are populating
up there um from there you know you have
now this energy that's like just
glowing inside of you to create and
that's where i start being like okay
what what can i you know i'm seeing
elements of this that really inspired me
what elements of this can i take to
create something that's my own
and and then that's where i'll start
toying around with
a scene it usually just starts with one
scene where i'll see that so crystal
clear
it's one of my favorite moments of the
creation process
um and then and then to write that scene
i i don't always start
a script from the very beginning i'll
sometimes start what i see the clearest
so i'll start with that and then
you know once you you've looked at that
scene and you kind of alright is the
rest of the story starting to fall into
place do i see what's going to be
happening now in this story
and if the answer is yes keep going so
then then i might start from the very
beginning okay let's get work our way up
to this scene and try and get there
um so i'll you know do the draft usually
the first draft is
i don't want to call it a mess because i
don't think it's a mess but it's it's
not
it's not textbook screenwriting you know
it's not perfect the actions aren't
purely actions the actions are a little
bit descriptive up there like i'm like
living in that flowery
description on my screen my first draft
of my screenplay um and i just love it
uh i think mark duplass referred to the
first draft like that as like the vomit
draft you're just getting the idea out
um and that's the perfect uh analogy for
it you're just
get this idea out i don't know it's a
gross analogy but you know you get it
so anyways you know you do that draft
and then that's where
all right are we going to do this are we
going to find the elbow grease to like
lift this up and like tighten the script
and you know usually around this point
aaron has already been
aware of like my passion for this script
like is this something you're interested
in too because i mean hey he's gonna be
the one directing
so is he gonna be attached as the
director and we'll kind of come together
and like start talking about the project
together he'll usually at this point
take it and uh if he if he hasn't
already sometimes we're both in the same
stage together but uh he'll he'll then
take it
and start really like polishing it up
and he does such a phenomenal job of
of absolutely tightening a script
anything that's extra superfluous that
i've been like putting in there because
hey
pizzazz and it needs to be in there
right it doesn't need to be in there he
takes it out
he can see as the director exactly what
it's going to be and so he takes it out
and he'll
he'll really tighten it and it becomes
this beautiful well-oiled machine and
i'm
so grateful because once he's had his
hands on it i mean if he he'll kick it
back to me
i'll read things and sometimes i'll be
like oh no you didn't see what needed to
be here in this scene did you not see
the emotional travesty that need oh no
this has to come back you know something
that's when we kick it back and forth
and i mean that's
the fun nerve-wracking probably
in aaron's opinion nerve-wracking
portion of the the
collaborative scriptwriting process
between us um
because i'm a very passionate writer if
you can't tell
um but we're always like on the same
team we're always
on the same team rowing in the same
direction to finish this script and
make it the best possible project and we
know that we both know that we both know
that
each of us wants the best finished
product so
we just keep kicking it back and forth a
few times once it's really polished and
ready to go
then we send it out to family and
friends and start getting getting the
feedback see what people think and
they give great notes we have fantastic
friends who read everything
and they give fantastic notes and we
listen we we really do it's not like
we're like
forget it they don't see it no we
totally listen and we're like oh i love
what they're that nugget of what they're
trying to tell us here let's try and
incorporate
that and fix that here
i break it down into seven steps based
similar to to blake's
system so and it's a simple way to say
it is i tell the store i get them to
tell the story or do my own work in one
sentence
and then five sentences and then 15
sentences which is like blake's 15 beats
and then 40 sentences which is basically
a sentence for each
scene in the movie more or less those
are the first four steps and then the
other three
are screenplay draft steps so you have
get it down
get it good and get it great um
and it's and it's a problem all those
and those things are
they're steps but they're really almost
like um
there's seven different ways the
audience is craving answers about your
story
and most writers that aren't like fully
firing on all pistons aren't answering
those questions as deeply as they could
so i'm good at doing that in my work at
least enough and then i get feedback and
i figure out how to do it even better
and when i work with other people i just
make sure that they're fully answering
those questions
and then when they get to the screenplay
writing part um
get it down as just as quickly as you
can
you're almost like formatting it i
usually tell like write a treatment
in that fourth stage after i do like the
40 um
sort of sentences for each scene i'll
kind of write that into a treatment five
pages 15 pages
and that was copy and paste that into
the screenplay format
and then i'm just almost reformatting it
cliche this cliche that doesn't matter
but just kind of scaffolding that's that
that
that um step um five
and then step six is get it good it's
not great it's just kind of okay you got
a mess of cliches and whatever but you
kind of organize it a little bit just
kind of
easy breezy momentum flow and then
after a few drafts of that you're like
okay this is working you're getting good
feedback
again we're in the reaction game so it's
not enough if you want to be
professional
that um that i dislike it's like i have
to like it and then
it's coming across other people and
they're saying it's great um
and then when you're getting that good
then you get into that fine tuning safe
get it get it great
so it's gonna get it down get it good
get it great
and what i see most mistakes they make
so this is that seven step process
inspired by blake's people will get a
loose idea right here
like step one and it'll jump to like
step seven and it's a
fiasco and even if they finish the
script um
you can see it the scripts is a mess um
and sometimes
you know if they tell me what their
script idea is in one sentence
um it'll it'll also be a mess and i can
just like
just by seeing the one sentence i know
the same problems they have in
a hundred page script one of the things
i added to to my process
that he doesn't really talk about is uh
starting with
the you know the log line and premises
is huge and then 15 beats is really
helpful but in between those two there's
i i do five sentences so act one
act two a or what blake calls fun and
games your midpoint
turn and then act two b and then act
three
so it's more or less the three act
structure but it's broken out into these
pieces i mean this is a turning point
but like it's so important to kind of
call it out
and so sometimes when i'm even coming up
with a movie idea for the
in the very beginning i'll kind of have
a couple pieces of the concept and i'll
actually maybe sketch it out
the five the five sentences but it's all
easy it's kind of like well oh i know
it's gonna end
and i'm not quite sure about this part
of that part so i just fill in what i
know
and go to the other parts and just kind
of play with it and then it just comes
together
if it's a good idea and if it's easy
it'll come together and if it's not
um coming together at least right now i
just put it aside do something else that
is easy
so specifically with the 40 um
you know 40 sentences for the scenes you
know again plus or minus
five or ten or whatever um i'll do that
and then i
i um so i so i have the sort of bone
structure of how i can go and i often
put them on index cards and a board in
my
my home office and um and uh and then
i'd like to go
from there before i go to the script to
actually write a treatment as well
for two reasons one is um
the uh those 40 cards are really good
for sort of
structural choices and sort of thread
flow and that sort of thing
but they don't get the feeling really of
the story so that's why i go to a
treatment
and then the second reason is you know
nobody's going to look at my 40 beats
and really
get what i'm doing so if i want feedback
and i get a lot of feedback in the
treatment stage
i write the treatment and then i can you
know five pages 10 pages whatever it
takes
the screenplay that i'm working on now i
actually did three drafts of the
treatment
got really good feedback between every
one then realized that i wanted to
change the protagonist from
one character to the other um and then
did three more drafts of the treatment
and then felt it was good and then i'm
into the screenplay so
by the time i get to the screenplay my
first draft
you know it's not really a first draft
because i've spent so much time
designing the story doing the treatment
it's it's
by probably a typical you know fifth
draft or tenth draft for other people
the first step is usually
[Music]
an idea of plot or story um
i don't really start with a character
i admire people that do that
um but i'm very much like
um you know stanislavski kind of outside
in
kind of thing like you know find the
shoes
and then you'll find the person as
opposed to the other way around kind of
thing
if that makes sense um so i usually have
an idea or a concept or story you're
going to want to tell
and and in writing it i find the
characters
i find the story and and then when i
know it's working whether that's
on an outline perspective or whether
it's in a draft perspective whether it's
draft one or draft
ten you know when the characters
suddenly start doing things
i don't want them to do then i know i've
got the characters right
and what i mean by that is that um
i can be writing and i can have an
outline and i can have a story and i can
i can know where i'm going
and then that character will just start
to say something
out of my fingers and it will start to
want to go through that door instead of
that door and like okay well let's go
there and see what happens
you know and it's i think that's partly
um
you know enjoying being flexible as you
write
you know and partly i think maybe that's
like
my very basic drama acting training
in me is that i can become those
characters i write them
in a way and i feel that and then
something in my being says well no i
wouldn't do that
you know as that character so it'll be
your plot needs something to do
but your character might not then you
get into that interesting
area of like well okay well let's
explore
what's down that corridor what's that
way and
yeah we want those characters to go um
so that that can be interesting that can
be that can be
a really pleasurable side of side of
writing
um and i i love structure i always start
you know with um
i really like save the cat the
controversial
but i feel that if i'm ever stuck or
i'm overwhelmed by like oh god i've got
a right like 1900 pages here like
how is my how is my idea my concept
which sounds cool
you know as a paragraph you know how
does that actually work as a feature
film
is it worthy enough to be a feature film
um
i do read that book or pick up that book
or you know look at
look at hero's journey or something like
that and i'll find that oh okay well
that's
why that's how i'm going to tell the
story i may not adhere to it
i you know part of knowing the rules is
breaking the rules if rules exist
i don't think they do but you know
there's a reason why
people like set up and pay off there's a
reason why
you know going back to the days of you
know telling a story around a campfire
or
you know or at a party you're tying a
good anecdote
you know like you don't suddenly come
out with the ending
it's just not it's not satisfying
there's there's we've
we've this idea of structure or the way
you tell stories is kind of somehow
ingrained in us
so you so you need to kind of understand
that or you almost need to
um play with the audience with that
either to
make them feel comfortable or to
completely subvert the thing that they
think is going to happen
like you know like all the big twists
that we know
that you know that we can reel off right
now all came because
the or the the structure or the style
film was setting up something we didn't
expect
and then it's turned kind of on its head
um and that's because
and i'm thinking about the m night
shyamalan sixth sense and that kind of
things
is that because as an audience we're
very astute to structure whether that's
you know
whether that's subconsciously or
consciously um that we always want to
try and be one step ahead
so when a film pulls the rug it's very
satisfying because
like we didn't see that coming i know
some people did see things that's coming
i didn't i loved it you know so
um so yeah that's that's how i would how
i would start is
from a concept start to apply to some
sort of structure
and then let the characters speak every
writer has to find their own process
so outlines don't work for everybody
beat sheets
don't work for everybody treatments
don't work for everybody you have to
figure out what works well for you
because i'm always thinking about what's
efficient and effective
for me most of the time because if i'm
writing a short
i only need to know the big beats right
i don't have to outline
the whole thing you know if i'm writing
a feature i need to outline the whole
thing because i don't i don't want to
get stuck
in the screenplay part that's
frustrating for me in my process
but if that's the part of the process
that you enjoy you can do it that way
i don't i don't tell people that it's
like a must but i do tell people
especially people who are learning or
people who
aren't learning but they've been writing
for a while and they're trying to make
it more efficient
you know so it's like no i've never
outlined before but i always end up
getting there
it's like yeah but do you get there in a
year because you might be able to get
there in three months
you know maybe depending upon what else
you have going on in your life you know
so definitely people don't have to do it
that way i think you have to figure out
what your process is
and and make sure that that process is
efficient for you again
if you're trying to be a professional
writer because you're trying that means
you're trying to
write more than one thing a year maybe
sell more than one thing a year
you can't do that if everything that you
write takes you know 15 drafts in two
years to write
so you want to look for something that's
more efficient and for me
writing the outline is just more
efficient